lunch money ftx i told you guys they
were gonna give out five thousand
dollars to two different people they
have selected the winners the winners
winner winner chicken dinner
is the email i got today
uh brian from texas and john from texas
and then it says both from texas we have
paid them thank you
i got questions as to how both people
from texas won i don't know is it rigged
i doubt it i didn't get to pick the
winner ftx picked the winner but two
people from texas brian and john both
from texas they won the five thousand
dollars each congratulations i
appreciate all of you i hope that you
are gonna do something cool with the
five thousand dollars that you got from
ftx for those of you who have not yet
signed up for ftx they are giving
bitcoin to folks if you go onto ftx sign
up for an account and you trade 500.
there's like 50 or so so go check it out
i just dropped the link in the chat
john brian from texas congratulations
all of you congratulations thanks for
showing up here today two hours let's
get started lunch money time plana how
are you i'm great people are saying they
like soup pump oh yeah bear marcus here
you all know the bear market costume we
got it ready to rock do we like suit
pump better than hoodie pump i don't
care i'm wearing the suit till we defeat
the bear market what's going on with the
fed i'm gonna bring a real bear in here
okay the federal reserve
the federal reserve today is expected to
do something it hasn't done
in 28 years wow i was two the last time
this happened wasn't even in the united
states didn't care uh they are about to
increase interest rates by three
quarters of a percentage point maybe
nobody knows likely nobody knows they
said they were going to do 50 basis
points then two days ago it got leaked
uh by the wall street journal that now
they may do 75 basis points but here's
the problem nobody knows we are
literally hours away from the press
conference and nobody knows are they
going to do 50 are they going to do 75
will they surprise us with 100 could
they pause nobody knows this is what
happens with a human-led monetary policy
is that nobody knows what they're going
to do later today what they're going to
do is they're going to get up there and
they're basically going to surprise
everyone it's like surprise we did 50
basis points or surprise we did 75 basis
points nobody knows and that's a huge
problem so i do think that it is an
increased likelihood obviously that 75
basis points because that seems to be
what was leaked but i do not think that
we can stay with confidence that's what
they're going to do until we hear what
they say because they don't know
is there a world where they don't even
hike it
where there's no rate hike i mean is
that an option yes but i do not think
that uh that is something that they are
likely to do i think that it has hit
home to them especially with the
inflation measurement being 8.6 percent
uh and it didn't peak in march as they
previously thought i think now it's hey
we got to be serious and that's why
they're likely to do 75 basis points if
i was a betting man i'm not but if i was
i'd say 75 basis points but we'll see
today
okay what's up with mortgage so fast
that is so fast so much time i got
things to do let's go
yeah okay so this is how do you learn
slow you can't learn so you have to
learn fast so mortgage rates jumped
sharply this week as fears of a
potentially more aggressive rate hike
you know from the federal reserve upset
financial markets the average rate on
the popular 30-year fixed mortgage rose
10 basis points to 6.28
on tuesday that's up from 5.5 a week ago
yo so that means it's the 30-year
mortgage rate is like a rocket
it's just going up how high you think it
could go
7.2 percent it's actually pretty good
yes yeah i think it could i think it
could break seven uh we'll see but i
think the key piece to this whole uh
kind of financial understanding is that
mortgage rates are determined by the
cost of capital the cost of capital is
determined by the federal reserve and so
this is just chain reactions and while
you're seeing the 30-year mortgage rate
go up remember people were getting rates
two three percent eight months ago now
we're doubling and we're at 5.5 last
week now we're at 6.28 uh this week it's
because they're watching the fed
increase the cost of capital the fed
increases the cost of capital the
mortgage providers say okay well what is
their cost what is our cost of capital
from where we can actually get the the
money and then what are we going to lend
it out at and the spread they end up
pulling in themselves and so at the end
of the day
if the fed continues to hike interest
rates we should expect all of these uh
other interest rates of mortgages etc to
continue to climb
and the
problem is that nobody knows when it
stops so it then brings the question if
you were to go buy a home today should
you get a fixed rate
30-year mortgage or should you actually
get a floating rate because you don't
know what's gonna happen in the future
and at the end of the day i think that
most people when they buy their primary
residence they want a fixed rate so they
actually can plan and they know what's
going on there's a lot of folks who buy
commercial real estate or investment
properties i've been talking to a whole
bunch of investors uh banks all these
people i'm just trying to get
information right now and what i'm
hearing in the real estate market is
that most of the investors are actually
going for some sort of variable rate or
adjustable rate because they do not know
what's going to happen in the future and
what it does is it leaves open the
optionality to potentially refinance
later if something changes in the market
it becomes advantageous so i think that
that's one of the big things is not just
rates are going up but also primary
residents people are much likely or much
less likely to take a ton of risk versus
investors they are more likely to have
access to various capital sources try to
refinance et cetera
all right
all right that's interesting all right
but you want to hear what's shocking to
me as everything is taking a nosedive
everything is in the red
suddenly
wonder a cloud kitchen on wheels it's a
company led by mark lore the serial
entrepreneur who
behind got jet.com diapers.com all that
stuff he
raised 350 million dollars led by bain
capital ventures and it values the
company at 3.5 billion
and it's literally a moonshot meal
delivery startup
why on earth is this happening right now
well mark lore obviously uh has built
some incredible businesses right uh one
of the jokes is we know marklor can
build big businesses but can he build
profitable ones ha ha right uh that's
the knock just get the knock out of the
way but with that said he sold jet.com
for i think it was three billion three
and a half billion dollars uh he sold
diapers.com like comfortable for him
well he he has built very uh
real businesses that obviously walmart
and amazon thought were valuable on top
of that he is valuable so somebody's
able to acquire a company and get him to
come work for them uh it ends up being
valuable so i think that's uh uh why
he's able to raise money is because
people expect him to be able to sell
these companies uh the pitch behind this
from what i understand
my brother joe did a podcast with him uh
so this is where i'm getting some of it
is that he basically has a food truck uh
but that food truck is using licensed ip
so it's super high-end
brands or menus chefs etc so it's not
like you know hey we make two dollar
tacos instead it's very high-end which
obviously if it's high-end means that
there's uh pretty wide margins compared
to other food uh strategies and then
what it does is it comes literally to
your house and makes it outside and then
brings it right inside and it's hot so
like there's a whole bunch of things
that you can analyze and say like all
right there's a food delivery element
there's this like high-end ip element
there's the cloud element so you could
change systematize it is he gonna
franchise is he not like like it's
interesting
but again food's a really hard space
food delivery is a really hard space and
then when you add those two together
like we're gonna make high-end food and
we're gonna do it in kind of like a
vertically integrated food delivery
system the first thing that jumps to
mind is like damn that's gonna be really
capital intensive hence why he's raising
350 million dollars so what ends up
occurring here is like if you have
access to capital you can take a shot
like this but the average entrepreneur
who wouldn't be able to go raise
hundreds of millions of dollars in every
round this would be nearly impossible
for them to actually go do because it is
so capital intensive yeah
somebody said you look like a spy kid
with your uh suit in apple watch
that's fine that's funny a spy imagine
if i had a calculator watch
calculating on the dot
um
okay wow you didn't even okay uh don't
even need to look
oh always aware of my surroundings head
on a swivel be ready so you don't have
to get ready
no you're gonna pull away now
all right what's going on netflix
netflix is planning a squid game reality
show with the record 4.56 million dollar
cash prize so basically after netflix's
squid game series was so popular it was
it was a series not a movie right yeah
series
it is now it has now approved a reality
tv series inspired by the hit show
and
somebody will win i guess 4.56 million
dollars in cash which is the largest
cash prize in reality tv history before
you say anything i read all these
articles but nobody said
nobody
nobody gave credit where i think
credit's due
mr beast thank you oh netflix pay my man
okay mr b should get a bag for this i
agree didn't he do that yes and he gave
away money netflix is just ripping off
mr beast's idea no it's not and no no no
by the way i don't think it's a bad idea
like obviously mr b's video did is just
as many views as the whole squid game
series so like it makes sense why they
want to do it but like everyone in the
media that's pretending that mr beast
didn't do this first or that this is
where the idea came from absolutely put
some respect on that man's name give him
a bag and everyone move on with your day
i do think it's a good idea for netflix
because they subscribers are down
they're gonna have to figure something
else out so i thought this was
interesting and that they are now kind
of like gamifying their things they're
trying to expand and that yeah and that
more i i completely agree
okay and for the sad news of the day
yeah
microsoft retires internet explorer
browser after a long beautiful 26 years
wow do you remember the first time that
uh you started to use the internet yes
what what do you remember
i remember going on weird chat rooms and
my parents like what are you doing but i
was like there's people here no no
i thought it was interesting that you
could communicate with other people i
never communicate i just like read which
let me tell you i'm re-evaluating a lot
if you're in elementary school those
chat rooms were terrifying but i never
like engaged
i just like was exploring the internet
on internet explorer
i am uh reevaluating a lot of things
what did you do on the internet well i
remember three things uh from my early
internet experience the first was my
parents used to scream at us to get off
the internet because they were scared
that someone's calling or they want to
use the phone or whatever
he was in college when the internet came
out
no i wasn't
uh second thing is uh
aol instant messenger
like if you were there
if you if you were popular on aim you
basically ran middle school
sorry this is lady i'm talking chat one
dot com
chat one that's not a thing it was a
real thing guys
maybe in bulgaria in america we didn't
check one it was live
all right the the the uh third thing
that i remember listen the third time
got one connecting get off that website
are you crazy here's the third thing i
remember ready
is i remember going to school and uh the
two things that they made us do in
school i thought was ridiculous was uh
they would put us on the computer like
you know the computer room or whatever
like there's a room just for the
computers and we would go in there and i
used to always want to just play oregon
trail you remember that game do you ever
play that game
or yeah see you see
hallway education classroom education
hallway education classroom education
where you shot up the aliens
this is stupid oregon trail is the og
computer game for a whole generation of
people what was the cameron one where
she would like search the world carmen
carmen carmen
san diego that was my favorite well you
just called her cameron so i don't know
how popular it was in your school uh so
if we think about uh
uh
uh the oregon trail i was always trying
to play that and they were always trying
to get us to use the internet i remember
thinking like this stupid like what do
y'all want me to do on the internet they
were like like you know look this up do
this i'm trying to play games over i'm
trying to do real life on the computer
oregon trail the other thing i remember
and for the young kids out there i don't
think they still do this but they were
uh
they would take a like a thing and they
would cover the actual keyboard it was
like this plastic thing that they put
over the keyboard and i had typing
classes
and i remember and i remember they'd be
like don't look and like
we didn't know how to type at the time
right when we got all this so i
literally remember the teacher would
walk to the other side remember like
pick it up where's the j alright
oh i thought you meant like the cover so
your keyboard doesn't get dirty do you
remember those like the no that was nerd
stuff i didn't care if my keyboard was
dirty i wanted to see the letters they
covered it so you couldn't see the
letters so that when you were typing
they were trying to get you to look at
the screen rather than type like this so
literally we had typing class right now
like people were like yeah typing class
was a thing
now if you went into a high school in
america and you're like we're gonna have
typing class you get laughed out of the
room the kids will be like get out of
here we gotta get jacob back on the show
so he can tell that 11 year old is
typing with his toes that's how that's
how uh good he is come on now
all right anything else that uh that you
got for us no the people are asking
where ask lunch money went well asked
lunch money nobody was asking lunch
money so if you guys start asking
questions in the comments go to the
comments uh use hashtag ask lm if you
put a good question there please ask
somebody said asl do you remember aso
don't get me started on that these days
i think the s is a little i'm pretty
sure people i'm sure that people would
get that was that was a great comment
yeah cleanest based uh but yeah asl the
s in asl is a little uh uh different
these days don't take my joke all right
that's fine thank you very much i
appreciate it hi
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time